la machine à images s'est installée dans
le château de Blois dans les années 90
depuis chaque soir d'été à la fin des
visites le son et la lumière prennent
leur quartier nocturne dans l'enceinte
du château royal une deuxième vie se
prépare
en fait ce matin et on avait regardé
avant ce qu'il proposait et on a vu que
le soleil magnifique pour que la magie
commence en coulisse trois techniciens
s'affairent dans une minuscule régie on
est au cinquième étage
ok c'est parti d'ici 28
vidéosprojecteurs et 13 haut-parleurs
dessine une ambiance visuelle et sonore
à la taille des façades du château
le contrôle on peut voir tout ce qui est
vidéoprojecteur donc l'état des
vidéosprojecteurs les lampes longueurs
son deuxième écran plus haut j'ai
retrouvé vidéo
donc je vois toutes les façades du
château je vois si la projection spage
bien
sur mon troisième écran en fait ça c'est
la timeline du spectacle c'est tout le
spectacle donc on voit le défilement de
tous les fichiers de spectacle là ça
correspond à une image de son lumière
c'est en fait le spectacle est
synchronisé avec la lumière et l'image
ce vidéo mapping dure 45 minutes une
féerie qui est chaque soir aussi une
prouesse technique
[Musique]
on reste on reste là justement pour que
les gens puissent avoir un spectacle au
niveau de du château de Blois
[Applaudissements]
ici c'est un lieu unique c'est
une lumière qui est très intéressante
culturellement
il est très joli donc non c'est magique
[Musique]
avec nos enfants Le Bretagne et c'était
une façon de leur faire découvrir
l'histoire du château plus ludique il y
en a un qui est fatigué
c'était vraiment super bon